aude roche ancien maire de tournus
incarcéré pas vraiment une surprise pour
les tournusiens l'arrestation peu de
roche pour vous cette surprise qua non
pas dix souffle vous attendiez ce qui
tombe pour une affaire de moeurs ou
plutôt de bronze des affaires
financières financière pour la plupart
des gens il semblerait qu'il ait pas de
surprise mais bon qu'at-il fait
exactement
je ne sais pas de cran la fihg a vu le
journal vite fait on the views de machin
bon choix entre autres incrédule jean
claude becousse maire de laives quand il
apprend dans la presse locale les motifs
de la mise en examen de claude roche
pour harcèlement et viol il tombe des
nues j'ai vu un peu le motif de son
arrestation et je vous cache pas que là
je suis resté un petit peu musée en ma
présence il a jamais manqué d'égards à
une femme
encore une fois de plus avoir vraiment
dérangé quoi ça peut être le cas à
l'époque un après des désaccords sur des
projets intercommunaux et celui d'un
centre commercial à tournus jean claude
becousse prend finalement ses distances
avec claude roche il ému et c'est nous
prendre à la sortie en dix ans jean cau
je comprends pas avec le centre leclerc
journée 201 points et où je les écoute
c'est bon quoi j'ai pris des coups de
couteau maintenant c'est terminé j'ai
plus rien à voir avec toi donc c'est
vraiment à l'été depuis ce jour là
depuis ces événements là entre nous il
se passe est absolument rien du tout
face aux scandales qui éclaboussent la
ville l'actuel maire de tournus reste
prudent c'est une affaire d'ordre privée
qui ne concerne pas les affaires
municipales
bien que claude roche est encore élu
municipal mais moi je n'ai jamais vu
conseiller municipal depuis les
élections de 2017
pour bertrand vos nous n'en avons pas
encore fini avec claude roche lis pas
dans le marc de café
mais je serais pas surpris si vous
revenez me voir dans quelques mois pour
me dire que il a à nouveau des problèmes
que la justice sur des affaires
financières
le procureur de la république de chalon
sur saône n'a pas souhaité faire de
commentaire une enquête est toujours en
cours